so I have five three-dimensional shapes
over here and I also have five names for
them and what I want you to do is pause
this video and think about which of
these shapes is a square pyramid which
of these is a rectangular prism which
one is a triangular prism which one is a
sphere and which one is a cylinder all
right now let's just work through this
together and really this is just
something to know because some people in
various subjects will sometimes throw
out these words so first let's start
let's think about which one is the
square pyramid so this shape here on the
right clearly looks like a pyramid and
the thing that makes it a square pyramid
is the idea that its base is a square
let me see if I can shade this in so the
base of this right over here is is a
square and so that's where the square
pyramid comes from if it's a triangular
pyramid then the base would only have
three sides but this is a square pyramid
so let me move this over there so that
is a square pyramid all right let's do
the next one which one is a rectangular
prism a prism you can view is a
three-dimensional object and since it's
since it's saying a rectangular prism
well the best one here that is
rectangular notice this shape right over
here is rectangular on every side and
it's three dimensions it is a prism and
so this is the rectangular prism so
let's move that over so that is our
rectangular prism now triangular prism
so this one is interesting if you look
at this shape right over here it has
sides that are triangles you see this up
here is a triangle and you see this down
here is a triangle although they're
connected by these rectangular sides and
this is actually what's called a
triangular prism in a square pyramid the
faces which are triangles all meet at a
point in a triangular prism you have two
opposite facing sides that
our triangles and you'll see all of
these in different orientations in
different you know sometimes it'll be
resting like this sometimes it'll be on
its side but this is a triangular prism
let me see that is a triangular prism
and so we have two left you might be
able to figure these out which one is a
sphere well when I think sphere I think
of like a globe and so this choice right
over here is clearly a sphere so let me
move that over let me move it over okay
so that one is a sphere and then last
but not least a thing that looks like a
can is a cylinder so let me move that
over so that is a cylinder and we're all
done and so these are just useful names
to know for shapes cylinder is your
connecting you have these two faces that
are circular and then they are opposite
each other it's kind of like a
triangular prism but instead of having
these hard edges because you have a
triangle you have a base that is a
circle and a top that is a circle